[Music]
in medieval times alchemists tried to
achieve the seemingly impossible they
wanted to transform lowly lead into
gleaming gold history portrays these
people as aged eccentrics but if only
they've known that their dreams were
actually achievable indeed today we can
manufacture gold on earth thanks to
modern inventions that those medieval
alchemists missed by a few centuries but
to understand how this precious metal
became embedded in our planet to start
with we have to gaze upwards at the
Stars Gold is extraterrestrial
instead of arising from the planets
rocky crust it was actually cooked up in
space and is present on earth because of
cataclysmic stellar explosions called
supernova stars are mostly made up of
hydrogen the simplest and lightest
element the enormous gravitational
pressure of so much material compresses
and triggers nuclear fusion in the Stars
core this process releases energy from
the hydrogen making the stars shine over
many millions of years fusion transforms
a hydrogen into heavier elements new
helium carbon and oxygen burning
subsequent elements faster and faster to
reach iron and nickel however at that
point nuclear fusion no longer releases
enough energy and the pressure from the
core Peters out the outer layers
collapse into the center and bouncing
back from this sudden injection of
energy the star explodes forming a
supernova the extreme pressure of a
collapsing star is so high that
subatomic protons and electrons are
forced together in the core forming
neutrons neutrons have no repelling
electric charge so they're easily
captured by the iron group elements
multiple Neutron captures enable the
formation of heavier elements that a
star under normal circumstances can't
form from silver to gold
pass led and on to uranium in extreme
contrast to the million year
transformation of hydrogen to helium the
creation of the heaviest elements in a
supernova takes place in only seconds
but what becomes of the gold after the
explosion the expanding supernova
shockwave propels its elemental debris
through the interstellar medium
triggering a swirling dance of gas and
dust that condenses into new stars and
planets Earth's gold was likely
delivered this way before being kneaded
into veins by geothermal activity
billions of years later we now extract
this precious product by mining it an
expensive process that's compounded by
gold's rarity in fact all of the gold
that we've mined in history could be
piled into just three Olympic sized
swimming pools although this represents
a lot of mass because gold is about 20
times denser than water so can we
produce more of this coveted commodity
actually yes using particle accelerators
we can mimic the complex nuclear
reactions that create gold in stars but
these machines can only construct gold
atom by atom so it would take almost the
age of the universe to produce one gram
at a cost vastly exceeding the current
value of gold so that's not a very good
solution but if we were to reach a
hypothetical point where we'd mined all
of the Earth's buried gold there are
other places we could look the ocean
holds an estimated 20 million tons of
dissolved gold but at extremely
miniscule concentrations making its
recovery too costly at present perhaps
one day we'll see gold rushes to tap the
mineral wealth of the other planets of
our solar system and who knows maybe
some future supernovae will occur close
enough to shower us with its treasure
and hopefully not eradicate all life on
Earth in the
[Music]